- [Instructor] So let's
see how we could approach
four and 1/4 minus two and 2/4.
Pause this video and have a go at that
before we work on this together.
All right, so the first thing
that you might try to do
is re-write this as four
and 1/4 minus two and 2/4.
And the reason why it's
useful to write it this way
is we could say look,
each of these mixed number
have a whole number part
and then they have a fractional part.
And so I could try to
subtract the fractional part
from the fractional part
and then the whole number part
from the whole number part.
And that will often work.
But when we go to just
the fractional parts
and we say hey, how do
I subtract 2/4 from 1/4,
2/4 is larger than 1/4.
You immediately might find yourself
in something of a conundrum.
So what do you do?
Well, what comes to the rescue
is a notion called regrouping
and that's that we're not
just subtracting 2/4 from 1/4.
We're subtracting two and
2/4 from four and 1/4.
So what we could do is we
could take some of the value
that's in this four and
regroup it into the fraction.
What do I mean by that?
Well instead of four,
if I view four as three and 4/4, 4/4.
And so 4/4 plus 1/4 is 5/4, 5/4.
So I could re-write this as three and 5/4
minus two and 2/4.
Once again, why is that useful?
Because 5/4 is greater than 2/4.
What is 5/4 minus 2/4?
Well that's going to be 3/4.
And then what is three minus two?
Well that's going to be one.
And we get one and 3/4.
Another way we could of thought about it
is this is the same
thing as four minus two
plus 1/4, plus 1/4,
minus 2/4, minus 2/4.
And we have trouble
with the 1/4 minus 2/4.
That's what we saw right over here.
So what we do is we take some
of that value from the four.
Instead of four we could
re-write that as three plus 4/4.
That's the same thing as four.
And of course you have minus
two plus 1/4 minus 2/4.
And then if you add the 4/4 to the 1/4
that's going to give us 5/4.
So you're going to have three minus two.
That's that part and that part.
And then you're going to have
if you add the 4/4 and the 1/4,
so plus 5/4 minus 2/4.
And that exactly what we have here.
Three and 5/4, three and 5/4
minus two, minus two, and minus 2/4.
And so three minus two is one.
5/4 minus 2/4 is 3/4.